[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans
parlement hebdo l'émission qui revient
sur les temps forts de l'actualité à
l'assemblée et au sénat on va encore
parler aujourd'hui des conséquences de
l'épidémie de covin 19es avec moi pour
présenter cette émission tam tran huy
bonjour ta main bonjour brigitte est
notre invité aujourd'hui marie noëlle
lienemann bonjour aux choux verts
sénatrice de paris et c'est anne qui
brosse votre portrait marie noëlle
lienemann vous êtes né à belfort mais
votre carrière politique vous amener sur
d'autres terres vous a fait bourlingué
du pas-de-calais à la capitale en
passant par l'essonne vous êtes
sénatrice de paris depuis maintenant
huit ans situés à la gauche de la gauche
vous avez appartenu en tant que ministre
du logement a deux gouvernements
socialistes
au début des années 90 sous mitterrand
et au début des années 2000 gouvernement
de lionel jospin
mais il ya deux ans vous quittez le ps
avec fracas le parti que vous qualifiez
de canard sans tête
alors où vous situez-vous aujourd'hui
pourquoi est ce que vous n'avez pas
clairement franchi le rubicon jusqu'à la
france est soumise à ce que ce ne sont
pas les seuls audible aujourd'hui à
gauche
alors d'abord nous avons créé avec
emmanuel maurel et nos amis du mrc qui
étaient proches de jean-pierre
chevènement un parti parce que la france
est soumise n'est pas un parti un parti
que je ne puis peut-être la gauche
républicaine et socialistes pourquoi
parce que nous croyons partie comme
outil qui permet des synthèses politique
des réflexions collectives qui s'inscrit
dans la durée dans une histoire et dans
l'avenir
donc nous pensons que la gauche
républicaine et manque aujourd'hui de
visibilité et doit mieux s'affirmer
je ne suis pas non plus quand vous dites
la gauche de la gauche je dirais que je
suis au coeur de la gauche parce
qu'historiquement on a quand même vu le
parti socialiste dériver vers le centre
quand je suis sympathique et vers le
libéralisme en tout cas moi je me sens
fidélité les parties sociales avaient
été déplacées ben oui la preuve c'est
que la plupart des français considèrent
qu'il est plus à gauche
donc voilà donc mois à partir de ce
moment là si j'avais pensé qu' on
pouvait encore transformer ce parti qui
se dévitalise ecc avait quand même
permis d'arriver donné manuel mâcon j'y
serais resté pour continuer mon combat
est aujourd'hui je vais une brûlure la
gauche je suis pour le rassemblement de
toute la gauche sans exclusive
or aujourd'hui j'observe gauche et
écologistes
qui est quand même l'émergence du monde
écologiste j'observe aujourd'hui que
tantôt un certain nombre de gens disent
toute la gauche sur jean luc mélenchon
je m'excuse c'est quand même lui qui
encore aujourd'hui incarne la plus
grande force dans cette dynamique là et
de l'autre côté
peut être une tentative ou une tentation
de considérer qu'on peut faire sans une
partie de la gauche réformiste à
condition qu en effet y ait pas
d'ambiguïté qui manuel macron donc je
suis pour le rassemblement autour d'un
programme offensif alors vous restez
avec nous voici tout de suite les types
de cette émission l'état d'urgence
sanitaire s'arrêtera le 10 juillet mais
le gouvernement prévoit ensuite une
sortie progressive un régime dérogatoire
pendant quatre mois qui fait grincer des
dents dans l'opposition il y avait déjà
deux commission d' enquête sur le kobe
de lancer par l'assemblée et le sénat
voilà que le gouvernement peut aussi
lancer sa propre évaluation de la crise
la crise économique succède à la crise
sanitaire un troisième projet de loi de
finances a été adopté en conseil des
ministres cette semaine
il porte l'effort financier à 460
milliards d'euros
et pour commencer cette émission
arrêtons nous sur le projet de loi
organisant la fin de l'état d'urgence
sanitaire
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
la date est fixée l'état d'urgence se
termine le 10 juillet mais il ya un mais
car un projet de loi présenté mercredi
en conseil des ministres prévoit qu'il
soit suivi par un régime dérogatoire
jusqu'au 10 novembre
une période de quatre mois pendant
laquelle le gouvernement à pouvoir
restreindre certaines libertés
un autre deux critiques un certain
nombre de sénateurs samia de sheer dans
un mois la france sortira de l'état
d'urgence sanitaire
mais pas forcément du régime d'exception
dans un projet de loi présenté mercredi
en conseil des ministres le gouvernement
prévoit de maintenir certaines mesures
de restriction des libertés pour quatre
mois supplémentaires soit jusqu'au 10
novembre
le conseil scientifique a fait état de
quatre scenarii d'évolution de
l'épidémie dans tous ces scénarii le
virus existent toujours tant que nous ne
disposons pas de traitement aux deux
vaccins il continue donc à circuler même
à bas bruit et il est donc nécessaire
que nous soyons armée pour pouvoir
répondre à cette situation
c'est la raison pour laquelle nous
n'avons pas souhaité qu'il y ait une
sortie sèche de l'état d'urgence
sanitaire
mais plutôt une sortie en biseau pour
une période transitoire de quatre mois
jusqu'au 10 novembre l'exécutif pourra
donc réglementer la circulation des
personnes
l'accès aux transports en commun et aux
lieux accueillant du public mais surtout
il pourra continuer de limiter ou
d'interdire tout rassemblement sur la
voie publique
pour l'opposition c'est une prolongation
de l'état d'urgence qui ne dit pas son
nom bien en prolonge l'état d'urgence
parce que la situation sanitaire le
justifie ou bien on le prolonge pas nous
allons entendre les informations
scientifiques sur l'état de l'épidémie
et nous verrons bien à ce moment là ce
que nous déciderons mais en tout cas
nous prendrons une décision
frange pas dans un entre deux le projet
de loi sur la fin de l'état d'urgence
sanitaire doit maintenant être adopté
par le parlement et au sénat la partie
semble pour l'instant mal engagée pour
le gouvernement et pour la présidente de
la commission des lois de l'assemblée
nationale et à yale brune peavey il est
nécessaire de sortir progressivement de
l'état d'urgence sanitaire en écoute à
l'idée c'est de faire une feinte d'état
d'urgence sanitaire progressive on ne
peut pas tout arrêté d'un coup et puis
il faut envisager la possibilité que
dans une zone où une autre sur le
territoire est lié peut-être une
recrudescence de cette épidémie donc il
faut garder quand même certains outils
donc ce projet de loi vise à cela on
arrête l'état d'urgence d'une façon
globale mais on conserve un certain
nombre d'outils ce d'autant plus qu'on
va rentrer en période estivale
il faut plutôt que le premier ministre
le gouvernement et les outils à
disposition pour pouvoir agir
immédiatement si besoin
donc voilà c'est organiser la sur la
sortie de façon progressive raisonner en
assurant la sécurité juridique des actes
qui pourront être pris au moment de
cette sortie et puis voilà on termine
tranquillement cette période cette drôle
de période
marie noëlle lienemann est ce que vous
comprenez ces précautions que prend le
gouvernement en cas de deuxième vague
pas de confinement mais d interdiction
ciblée est ce que c'est utile quand on
voit par exemple que l'épidémie peut
reprendre avec les derniers événements
en meurthe-et-moselle ciblées mais
décidée par qui parce que c'est toujours
le même problème
bon moi personnellement je pense que ce
qu'a dit philippe bas pour le coup je
suis pas souvent d'accord avec nick tout
cas pas toujours et il a raison soit on
sort de l'état d'urgence on rentre dans
le droit commun mais il ya toujours la
possibilité dans le droit commun s'il ya
un problème quelque part de prendre une
mesure et en particulier entre s'il ya
un travail sérieux avec le parlement de
pouvoir très rapidement délibéré s'il ya
besoin de modifier on est pas un dit
situation exceptionnelle cette crise
sanitaire dont on mai et prévoit revient
à lille deuxième à l'union européenne
ils ont fait état d'urgence
donc ils vivent quand même ils ont pris
des mesures quand même et qu'on arrête
de nous faire croire que dans ce pays on
n'a pas d'outils pour agir quand il ya
un problème majeur qui se pose quelque
part c'est pas vrai donc là il ya un
problème espèce de culture de
généraliser l'état d'urgence je vous
rappelle qu'une partie au moment du
terrorisme partie des mesures dites
d'urgence sont fini par rentrer dans le
droit commun et on voit bien comment
petit à petit tout l'art 2020 d'ailleurs
un simulateur de l'état d'urgence ce
sécuritaire jusqu'en 2020 voilà qu'il en
soit de même quatre mois moi personne
non mais alors la tonne et le chou parle
de lancer un sur le dos min de jeu
également là cette fois oui oui non mais
c'est chaque fois 2020 puis après c'est
encore plus longtemps puis au cas où on
sait jamais non il faut que le droit
français et il est applicable pour les
situations d'urgence fait que vous
accusez ce gouvernement finalement
depuis à 2017 puis la loi sylt de porter
atteinte aux libertés publiques
je pense que petit à petit on grignote
sur les libertés publiques
je pense aussi qu'on grignote plus qu'on
grignote on affaiblit le parlement et
ont fait croire que c'est par un coup
d'ordonnancé d'ailleurs pas seulement
sur ces sujets de d'urgence
c'est l'exécutif qui sait mieux faire -
a vu l'exécutif 1 il ya quand même eu
d'énormes eu d'énormes
dysfonctionnements pour ne pas dire de
fautes et d'erreurs donc le non ça n'est
pas une faiblesse d'associer le
parlement aux décisions publiques et en
particulier quand il s'agit des libertés
où il faut tremblay quand on modifie
nous loi sur ce sujet c'est une
tentation convoi dans la plupart des
pays
parce que comme le libéralisme créer un
système d' inégalités accrues de
violences accrues de violence sociale
mais aussi de violences
d'autres violences mais la réponse et il
faut absolument un projet de loi il
avait pour but d'interdire les
rassemblements de nuque de pouvoir
confiné c'était une erreur le
confinement moi je pense que le
confinement était la conséquence pour
une large part en tout cas le
confinement généralisée et est la
conséquence d'un curry au début de la
pandémie et jal était auparavant parce
que la france ne s'était pas bien
préparé y a pas que la responsabilité de
cette exécution ratée je rappelle quand
même j'avais souvent protester contre
les politiques d'austérité budgétaire
notamment dans le domaine de la santé ou
de la protection et en particulier quand
on avait soi disant pour des
rationalités de fonctionnement réunit
toutes les instances qui était censé
faire le suivi sanitaire du pays
on a supprimé les us ou lapsus je sais
plus quel était son nom exact et du coup
on sait on a perdu des outils d'alert et
préparation donc moi je pense que le
confinement
il aurait pu être moins long peut être
plus circonscrit dans le la géographie
est en tout cas il est plus l'incurie
que le manque d'outils
je vais dit pour agir en revenir sur le
régime dérogatoire sur les quatre
prochains mois
vous avez des craintes sur la liberté de
manifester ont longtemps déjà
l'opposition entend les regarder
l'histoire des infirmières qui voulait
faire grève ou les paramédicaux qui
veulent faire grève le 16 le 16 on
interdit les manifestations ils
manifestent tous les jeudis aujourd'hui
là où il ya la loi ogm autorisé je
m'excuse la loi elle est pas là pour
être à géométrie variable
on a le droit ou n'a pas le droit donc
il fallait rien dire le rassemblement
maintenant pour georges pahud le nord
non je dis simplement que c'est pas la
peine d'aller faire une loi pour dire
qu'on va interdire
on peut toujours interdire une
manifestation trouble à l'ordre public
y a pas besoin d'avoir une loi d'urgence
si le préfet considère qu' à troubler
l'ordre public parce qu'il ya une menace
sanitaire ces troubles à l'ordre public
y a pas besoin de cela d'ailleurs ils se
gênent pas pour les interdire mais je
vous dis je vois bien la pression qui a
pour essayer de tuer les mouvements
sociaux ou alors on donne le sentiment
qu'on laisse faire et que la loi mais
elle s'applique à géométrie variable
l'émotion n'est pas ça les règles
juridiques à double ça sympa c'est un
débat acceptable acceptable est saluée
hier par une partie de la gauche qui a
dix mois moi je pense que les règles
juridiques doivent permettre que
l'émotion s'exprime et là on met des
règles juridiques inadaptée qu'on
respecte pas et après eh bien comment
les expliquer que c'est selon que vous
serez puissant ou misérable
circonstances l'état de l'opinion
non les lois les les règles jolie
doivent permettre à l'émotion populaire
ne s'exprimer si je comprends bien vous
ne voterez pas ce projet de loi visant à
nantes hier l'état d'urgence sanitaire
je suis pour sortir mais je suis contre
les dérogations
donc je voterai la sortie sans les
dérogations et si on m'oblige à bouter
les dérogations a sans doute vaut en
tout cas je ne voudrais pas aller on
poursuit cette émission avec dans
l'actualité également au parlement
l'annoncé par l'elysée de mission d'
enquête indépendante pour évaluer la
gestion de la crise sanitaire
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
l'objectif de ces missions porter un
regard indépendant et transparent sur la
situation et à avoir un retour
d'expérience explique l'exécutif
un but qui froisse les sénateurs ce
dernier lance d'ailleurs les travaux de
leur commission denquête fin juin jérôme
radiés l'elysée a soigneusement fait
fuiter l'information aux médias
l'exécutif souhaite lancer sa propre
commission d' enquête sur la gestion de
la crise l'objectif de cette troisième
commission serait de porter un regard
indépendant et transparent sur la
gestion de la crise par l'exécutif est
d'avoir un retour d'expérience dans sa
dimension sanitaire
ce qui a fait bondir le président du
sénat gérard larcher qui évoque sur les
réseaux sociaux sa stupéfaction en
apprenant la nouvelle
il aurait même d'abord cru à une fake
news mais depuis cette annonce le
gouvernement fait bloc et défend l'idée
d'un retour d'expérience courant dans le
monde de l'entreprise
je suis très surprise parce que si nous
n'avions pas nous-mêmes travailler à
améliorer nos processus de décision tout
le monde se serait écrié que c'est
scandaleux et après je veux dire il y a
le temps de l'exécutif
eliya le temps des parlementaires autant
dire que du côté des parlementaires de
l'opposition l'initiative fait bondir
pour le futur président de la commission
d' enquête sénatoriale
c'est un scandale institutionnels c'est
un geste antidémocratique de première
grandeur il y à l'assemblée nationale
qui a sa propre commission denquête le
sénat qui a la sienne le sens que c'est
largement suffisant en tout cas la
constitution avait prévu la liberté des
parlementaires sur le sujet même
indignation à la gauche de l'hémicycle
pour le patron du groupe socialiste au
sénat cela va laisser des traces dans
les relations parlement exécutif ça peut
être aussi un acte de défiance du
gouvernement à l'égard du parlement
alors que le parlement a été tout à fait
à la hauteur depuis le début de cette
crise et donc c'est tout à fait dommage
d'autant que la commission denquête de
l'exécutif veut aller vite très vite
même avec un rapport prévu cet été
les parlementaires rendront eux leurs
conclusions d'ici la fin de l'année en
espérant montrer que l'indépendance du
parlement permettra un véritable bilan
de l'action du gouvernement pendant
cette période et précisons que selon le
canard enchaîné il va y avoir
deux missions une mission d'experts
scientifiques et un audit financier de
la cour des comptes
marie noëlle lienemann est ce que c'est
une bonne chose parce que ce n'est pas
complémentaire par rapport aux
commissions d'enquêté parlementaires que
cette initiative de l'exécutif ou de
l'art de noyer le poisson parce que
emmanuel macron elle gouvernements
savent qu'ils ont large part de
responsabilité dans le non pas le
déclenchement de virus c'est clair mais
la manière dont la france ne s'est pas
armé de manière opérationnelle et n'a
pas tenu un discours de vérité aux
français
g rappelez vous l'histoire ne faut pas
mettre de masse ça sert à rien à l'été
ça sert à rien enfin bon bref on connaît
tout cela c'était en fait nous dit noyer
le poisson mais la commission attendait
les 30 secondes noyer le poisson parce
que tout la bhl
tout l'art va être de donner des
messages tous azimuts pour dire dans
tout se vaut il ya du pour y a du coup
annoncé hier personne n'est responsable
de rien et ça va accroître la crise
démocratique
premièrement qu'est ce qu'ils ont dit
sur les commissions d'enquêté de
l'assemblée ce que ne l'était pas elle
n'était pas impartiale et indépendante
mais la meilleure indépendance c'est le
pluralisme
c'est le fait que dans cette commission
vous ayez des gens de tous bords
politiques représentant le pays
deuxièmement elles sont transparentes
toutes les auditions son public il n'ya
pas le confinement entre les gens du
même milieu qui discutent entre elles
on sent et on voit bien qu'il ya un
travail très important de relations
entre l'opinion publique et le parlement
on l'a vu dans d'autres commissions
dockett il ya des gens qui réagissent
sur les réseaux sociaux qui nous
appellent en disant pourquoi vous ai pas
posé telle question donc ça permet de
nourrir le débat localisé dans un train
une instrumentalisation politique
finalement donné on a tous en tête la
fermer et en quoi ce instrumentaliser
politiquement benalla on a fait notre le
le sénat fait son travail l'a transmis à
la justice c'est pas lui qui juge la
justice a rendu son jugement le rappel
de liant de tension qui avait eu entre
l'exécutif et le parlement à cette
occasion mais vous croyez eu des
stigmates dans les relations entre
l'inde et mais on s'en moque des
relations c'est les citoyens kong - de
savoir il faut qu'on sache qu est ce qui
s'est passé qu est-ce qui a
dysfonctionné deuxièmement les retours
d'expérience dont il se trouve que
j'étais ministre
moment de l'expérience de là l'explosion
azf à toulouse et on le voit dans le
rapport heureusement qu'à la commission
d' enquête sur lubrizol
ah oui sur pourquoi et comment etc parce
que qu'est-ce qui se passe il faut en
effet l'administration elle-même les
l'administration c'est à dire l'état qui
normalement n'est pas totalement vendu
100 % au gouvernement il ya une certaine
neutralité doit rendre des comptes et
expliquer son retour d'expérience propre
mais cela n'empêche pas l'autre les vers
10 h 30 secondes il fait les commissions
officiellement le mental non non
l'exécutif doit faire travailler son
administration
3 un truc et c'est pas l'elysée qui
gouverne le pays
c'est le premier ministre allemand cette
initiative allait contraire aux
institutions moi je trouve qu'elle elle
elle parasite elle elle cherche à noyer
le poisson pour éviter les
responsabilités et faire que tout se
vaut deux elle discrédite le parlement
et notamment son côté pluraliste qui
garantit plus d'indépendance que tout
autre parce que les autres ils vont être
nommés par le président vous croyez
qu'ils vont nommer des gens qui vont
être très hostile à leur politique non
et par ailleurs ça tue l'idée d'un état
qui est porteur de l'intérêt général
avec une certaine neutralité qui lui
même avec tous les défauts que je trouve
un haut fonctionnaire technocrates et
autres doit pouvoir expliquer aux
citoyens son retour d'expérience en tant
qu'etat en lien évidemment avec
l'exécutif
mais en tant qu'etat et c'est dans la
confrontation de ces trois regards que
nous devons quitte à ce que l'état
demande et des scientifiques des regards
croisés mais c'est à travers ces trois
regards que les français doivent pouvoir
là l'exécutif
il y aura un benchmark avec les autres
pays ce que nous pensons évidemment
qu'elle n'a pas dans une entreprise le
benchmark est à notre pays
vous êtes vous et a fait le buzz est une
corvée certaines crises mondiales ont
pas pouvoir vous croyez que le sénat il
parlement vont pas regarder ce qui s'est
passé ailleurs ils vont auditionner
aussi des personnels et bien ça nous
arrive très souvent de d'auditionner
mais en plus regarder comment comparer
la suède et la france la suède c'est
gros comme ronald pendant d'habitants et
s'est étalé sur un territoire très vaste
pourquoi le coc vite s'est pas déplacé
en allemagne avec la montre s'est recalé
dit
cision allemande il ya aussi si je puis
dire on pourrait dire la moitié de la
france ouest
elle est vachement bien organisés tandis
que la moitié est
c'est vraiment dégueulasse puisque il ya
eu essentiellement sur l'est le coc vide
et beaucoup moins sur l'ouest
on voit bien qu'il ya d'autres critères
que simplement parce que vous êtes
français parce que machin le système il
ya des choses à tirer quand ça marche
bien quelque part
par exemple c'est inacceptable que
l'indépendance en matière de tests en
matière de matériel
l'allemagne on est davantage que la
france ça il n'y a pas besoin de 25
mille experts étrangers pour vous le dit
précisons que d'ailleurs à la commission
des enquêtes du sénat prévoit des
déplacements en allemagne pour bien sûr
de comparaison on le voit quand même
leur est maintenant vraiment aux
critiques
est-ce que tout de même il ne faudrait
pas renouer avec une part de l'unité
nationale qui est apparu au plus fort de
la crise y compris dans ce moment pour
bien penser à la prêt pour bien faire le
bilan aussi de cette période il faut cei
le français le principe même de la
raison en france c'est le regard
critique sur le réel et la capacité de
nous mobiliser autour de projets communs
c'est ça qu'il faut qu'on fasse et
l'unité c'est pas faire l'autruche
ferment on va pas se fâcher les gars
tout va bien non faux avec lucidité sans
sans acrimonie excessive mais avec une
lucidité absolue est en tout cas des
points de vue à ce que deux aimants oui
je suis pour une mobilisation générale
mais on ne mobilise pas les français
autour d'un unique
l'unanimisme béland derrière le chef l
exécutif on est encore plus quand on
voit que toute une série de nos
concitoyens reste les oubliés des
politiques publiques alors qu'ils sont
souvent les propositions du gouvernement
d'union nationale n'a pas de sens il
faut que le débat ait lieu mais on peut
être mobilisé en débattant qu'est ce que
c'est que cette idée qu'il faudrait être
on n'est pas en n'est pas l'armée et
encore quand on discute l'armée coût
d'entrée quand même mais on n'est pas je
ne veux voir qu'une seule tête au
contraire où toutes les énergies se
sentent utiles à l'avenir du pays que
tous ceux qui ont des projets des envies
de fer qui ont envie de se former qui
ont envie depuis se sentir partie
prenante des énergies qui vont être bien
utile
n
ces serres puisqu'on va maintenant
s'intéresser dans la crise économique
conséquence de l'épidémie de covin et de
trois un troisième projet de loi de
finances rectificative a été présenté
cette semaine en conseil des ministres
dans la foulée bruno le maire a défendu
ce nouveau budget en commission alors en
dépit des milliards prévus pour relancer
l'économie
un consensus politique ne semble pas se
dégager l amende à gaza un troisième
collectif budgétaire pour faire face à
la crise sanitaire devenue crise
économique
je rappelle que l'ensemble des sommes
qui sont consacrés à cette réponse à la
crise économique représente avec ce plfr
3 460 milliards d'euros
c'est 20 % de la richesse nationale
française c'est l'équivalent du produit
national brut de l'autriche
c'est donc une réponse massive et je le
redis efficace qui a été apportée à
cette crise dans ce budget rectificatif
45 milliards d'euros pour les secteurs
les plus fragilisées 18 milliards pour
le tourisme 15 milliards d'euros pour
l'aéronautique ou encore 8 milliards
d'euros pour le plan automobile
pour ce troisième projet de loi de
finances rectificative en trois mois la
droite réclame dorénavant un cap
globalement où va-t-on quand on a quand
on est face à des chiffres de cette
ampleur ce serait assez important
peut-être de conduire le pays vers un
tout petit peu plus de lucidité vous
égrainé des plans sectoriels je le
comprends ce les secteurs qui souffrent
le plus il faut évidemment le faire mais
où est la vision d'ensemble
les oppositions de gauche elle propose
une taxation des plus hauts revenus
il me semblait qu'en période
exceptionnelle en était en droit de
demander un effort exceptionnel une
contribution exceptionnelle aux plus
aisés nous aurions préféré que cet
argent public investi trouvent le moyen
de faire contribuer un peu plus le
capital financier à l'effort réclamé à
toute la nation les prévisions
économiques pour cette année s'aggrave à
nouveau le déficit s'élèverait à 11,4
pour cent du pib
marie noëlle lienemann 460 milliards
d'euros jusqu'ici
injectés dans l'économie qu'est ce que
vous pensez de la gestion de la crise en
matière d'économie par ce gouvernement
je crois qu'il fallait agir injecter
massivement de l'argent public je me
réjouis d'ailleurs qu'on le découvre que
l'état a un rôle économique majeur et
pas seulement et c'est là des réflexions
qu'il faudra avoir même sur la mise en
oeuvre du plan s'est pas seulement la
voiture balai quand le système va pas
pour qu'ensuite on empoche les profits
et les bénéfices quand ça va mieux en
certains empochent les profits
donc premièrement d'accord avec ces
stratégies deuxièmement je vois bien
poindre avec les propos de monsieur
woerth
la bonne vieille rengaine de la gauche
de la droite par ton contre la gauche
faute ou faudra arriver faut être
prudent faudra faire de l'austérité
faudra revenir vraiment passé dans le
débat de la dette parce qu'on sait tous
les gains vont peser non pour une raison
simple c'est de l'histoire de la france
est faite de dettes nord de la france du
monde et le fait d'être non remboursés
alors on étale dans la durée je veux pas
rentrer la technique je veux dire les
manques il ya aujourd'hui parce qu'ils
sont aujourd'hui
terrible pour une partie des français
c'est sur le cap social première
premièrement tous ces chômeurs qui ne
sont pas indemnisés qu'on appelle les
intermittents de l'emploi c'est un
million deux cent mille voire amis ont
cinq cent mille de personnes qui n'ont
en rien c'est à dire qu'ils sont
indemnisés de rien parce qu'ils étaient
extras dans le bâti dans le tennesse est
marquée notamment par les dispositifs de
chômage partiel ils ont été très
généreux
vous êtes mettez tout de même que ce
type de dispositif elles ne peuvent pas
continuer à voler mais ternat mme
advitam eternam certainement pas plus
longtemps jusqu'en septembre octobre
oui tous les économistes montrent que
c'est un mécanisme qui est à la fois
pourvoyeur de pouvoir d'achat maintient
les gens dans l'entreprise et permet aux
entreprises de rigaud d'essayer de
limiter la casse mais si j'écoute
ben oui ça coûte mais ça coûte aussi 15
milliards
quand pour l'automobile etc donc oui ça
coûte
en revanche il faut bien contrôlée qui a
pas d'abus
ça je pense que le gouvernement a
conscience de très bien il y en a bon
vieux le leem en est il ya une urgence
absolue au chômage à l'indemnisation du
chômage des intermittents du spectacle
et la première page du spectacle
de l'emploi parce que ceux du spectacle
sont réglés pas les autres et ceux là
sont très fragiles donc vous ne demandez
pas lier ça vous dit finalement les
traités de 30 secondes laissez-moi
terminée il ya deux aces 30 secondes à
wisches et bien mais justement pour moi
c'est important deuxièmement les jeunes
il faut mettre le rsa pour les jeunes
tout de suite
troisièmement il faut mieux conditionner
les aides en tout cas faire un accord
pour que les aides relance industrielle
permettent la mutation pas de fermeture
de site
on doit travailler à la mutation des
sites industriels existants et enfin
faire contribuer les plus riches
les mouvements financiers et les gaffes
à à la relance de notre pays c'est
beaucoup marie noëlle lienemann c'est le
mot de la fin merci beaucoup à tout
d'abord c'est à cette émission
on se retrouve la semaine prochaine pour
un nouveau numéro de parlement hebdo
[Musique]